now is a good opportunity as you're
jotting down some working um to explain
some of the language that's in the
question
that's kind of um it's kind of there to
provide an explanation for why some of
the numbers are what they are
i didn't want to focus on them because
this is a mathematics lesson not an
economics lesson but
there's a blurry line between those
so let me explain what you're looking at
and deposits a hundred dollars
the end of each year by the way as
you've already noticed in previous
questions
that's important we're not just
providing that piece of information to
you out of curiosity
uh the fact that it's at the end of each
year is going to have an impact on the
equations that you form um he deposits
that money into and then you're like
what's this about oh
god now that you've said that and
aggressive superannuation fund you're
like i'm not used to seeing the word
aggressive come up
in my mathematics lessons and i'm
putting it there on purpose
um what does an aggressive fund mean
it's taking as you can see in the
question it's taking risks
high risks risks that mean when you
invest that money sometimes you're going
to make a loss
in fact if you go and do some research
into aggressive investment funds one of
the things they say to you right at the
start is
if you take it for say 10 years we're
going to give you the heads up now that
within that 10 years
you are likely to make losses like three
to four times at least that's the nature
of the risks
that we're taking it's volatile is
another good way to say it
but the upshot of taking those bigger
risks is
uh you make this massive interest rate
you can see down the bottom here 10
interest per annum which is a lot higher
than what would happen if you take
conservative
investments that you won't probably lose
money on but um because they're so safe
you're also less likely to make larger
margins larger
profits so the key figures of course are
a hundred dollars that's not a figure
but it's an important
reality it's at the end of each year
you've got an interest rate there ten
percent per annum because nothing else
has been said
you can assume it's compounding annually
and then you're going with
this one last piece of information that
you'll need for the question which is
uh how long which is nine years so
question is it
ten percent starting from the hundred
dollars or is it ten percent accumulated
after the
like you know you said that it happened
over time
so this is this is a really good
question right so there's 10
interest per annum right it applies to
whatever amount of money whatever
quantity of money
is in the superannuation fund yeah so
let's just think about and i'm actually
giving you a leg up into the question
already but you ask the questions that's
fine uh let's think about day
one day one first of january just for
the sake of simplicity
how much money read the question
carefully it's not a rhetorical question
on the first of january how much money
is in the bank account
look again carefully on the 1st of
january
there is no money in the count because
he deposits when
at the end of each year on the 2nd of
january there's nothing there on the
third on the fourth
on the 30th of december there is nothing
there
but at the end on the 31st he makes an
investment you might say that's a bit
weird you're like why would he wait all
that time
um the first answer is just because of
convention but it will become a little
clearer later on
um in fact i'm even going to say after
ap fours
why i'm phrasing the question in this
way okay so i'm just setting the seed
i'm just going to say
we'll come back to it i promise but for
now that's going to form our equations
did you have a question or a suggestion
yeah i'm good i'll keep it to myself for
now
um mrs liz i'm kind of number of people
who've just shown me a compound interest
formula
with an answer why would that not be the
best approach to take for this problem
why wouldn't we just pull out a compound
interest
formula there's um there's a single word
in this question that tells you
actually i mean there's more than one
but there's one in particular that tells
you
this is not just a compound interest
situation
on its own you can't just take that
number that interest rate nine years and
then off you go
anyone want to give me a suggestion what
words
so superannuation is is kind of like a
big flashing sign
right annuation of course in
superannuation means
it happens annually every year right but
but even before you got to
superannuation
look earlier look earlier before
aggressive
at the end of at the end of what each
year
each year he puts in more money a
deposit happens once then it happens
again
and again and again the compound
interest formula doesn't take care of
that it's just
a single body of money and it grows
according to interest
we'll come back to that idea i promise
but for now i want you to recognize
this is not just a compound interest
question it's going to require it's
building our knowledge we've worked on
for the last
week and a half have a think okay i'll
hit pause again
and let you have a go you know how to do
these questions we have
working not just to like arrive at an
answer
but to convince us that that answer is
right
i was saying it's apparent before um i
wrote this question
as you can see by my handwriting and so
i didn't have like some answer key
or someone else i could ask like please
tell me what the solution is so that i
can check that i'm correct
i had to use my working just like you
have to use your working
to convince yourself to show that the
logic is watertight and that you come up
with a number
which actually is correct now the reason
i know that that's
not what a lot of people have been doing
in the room is they're showing me a
calculator and it's got a number on it
and that's it and there's no working
that we can say oh i can see where that
calculation came from i'm convinced
right um i worked this out some time ago
i didn't remember what the number is
the number is not the thing that's
important to me it's the way that you've
argued and constructed
the reason for that number so let's
begin you can see
i've started out with some words if you
have begun your working without any
words
like this then we already are in some
trouble because you might start talking
about a this or a that
but i don't even know what a means is it
at the start of the years at the end of
the year
that kind of really matters right the
second thing you might notice is unlike
in previous questions
i often start from a naught which sounds
weird like why why start counting from
naught who does that right
well the answer is i often do it
depending on what's happening in the
question
in this case i have not and i wonder if
anyone can give me any suggestions for
why i've gone straight to the end
of the first year not the end of the
zero with you what do you think steve
um
sorry it's because um that's already one
year when he's put that installment in
so it is year one
as opposed to year zero very good so in
order to write something meaningful for
this equation right
something has to have happened there's
no point putting down before anything
has actually occurred
if i put down a0 here what happens at
the end of the zeroth year
according to this question nothing has
happened when does he put in his first
installment his first deposit it's at
the end of the first year which is
exactly how i've defined this okay
now on some other question i might call
a the start of the year
or i might say a0 is the thing that
matters you have to like this is one of
the key differences between the advanced
course
and the standard course you're both
looking at the same idea the same
concept
you're still doing the same calculations
but we expect you guys to actually be
able to
handle and explain a variety of
different situations and not just assume
it's one way or another
so i'm going to start with this first
year and i have this 100
okay he's made a deposit has anything
else happened at the end of this first
year
sean you shook your head at me pretty
quickly no why do you say that
what's what's your thought the question
that just literally said tells us
i'm just going to pause for a second
just going to wait forever's attention
just to heaven
so shaun you're saying the question
itself says a deposit has happened and
that's
all so did you ever want to add
something or did you want to question
something if it's put in at the end of
the year it hasn't generated
any sort of interest okay very good so
i'm going to put together i think those
thoughts
have it captured perfectly first it says
that's all that happens but we can infer
like
interest happens when the money's been
in there for some time and then we're
like oh
i should i should earn something back
for that fact but it only came in right
at the very end
so it hasn't been in there long enough
to actually earn any interest does that
make sense
cool so then we can start to build this
pattern
right and if you launched into a formula
as many of you did without establishing
this pattern it's just kind of a recipe
for disaster
even for those of you who there were a
couple of you who had the right answer
on your calculator
but you didn't know that it was right
and you're not going to get full marks
anyway because you haven't justified why
it is right
a year elapses what happens
so interest happens to this right
because you had this first amount and
it's been there for 12 months right
so i'm going to multiply by my interest
calculation
and then as the question says at the end
of that year
i put in a new deposit so there becomes
another 100 are you okay with that
yeah um it was a bit superfluous really
to write this in because there's just
one thing there
but i think it's important that we show
the pattern
where did this come from you start from
where you ended okay all right
i'm going to a3 because i always need
three terms
to establish a pattern yeah ah
that's a good question actually i did
kind of um float over that really
quickly
i quickly followed over this step but we
sort of do it quite frequently so that's
why i didn't label the point
even though some people i said don't use
the compound interest formula because
more than compound interest is happening
but compound interest is happening to
each individual
deposit and that's what this part is
it's really the one plus
r to the power of n right so it's 1 plus
r the r is 0.1 it's 10 percent
and the n in this case is 1. it's only
been there for one year
okay so that's the shorthand path for
that
all right one more to establish the
pattern third year
what's happened well it's going to be
eight
okay i start with where i ended okay and
then what happens to that
yeah good it attracts interest right
it's been there for a year you did
better
and then at the end of each year one
last thing happens
then deposit goes in so plus 100
okay let's go ahead and actually crunch
this out so here's a2 in the previous
line
so i'm going to multiply everything in
this line by 1.1
yeah there's the first term here comes
the second term
and then here's the final or the third
deposit this final for
this point right here okay do you see
the pattern that's formed you okay with
that